what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff2022
for a show this is a show interview a
show that i absolutely adore i was just
blabbing a clia about this but this is
one of the best things that i've watched
at tiff and i'm mad at you all because i
got the full season and i wanted to
watch the whole thing and it just
derailed all the movies that i needed to
watch to prepare for these interviews
congratulations thank you so much all
right tegan and sarah i wanted to start
with you just to walk us through the
beginnings of this
whose idea was it to turn your story
your memoir into a show was it your idea
or did someone come to you with a plan
well sarah told the story the other day
that apparently when we were pitching
the book to our book agent uh mark
gerald that we hadn't even come up with
what the show was going to be about but
uh sorry what the book was going to be
about but i was like this is going to
make a great tv show so which is why
clea called teagan and not me yeah
so then fast forward uh maybe a year and
a half later we had sent an early copy
to clea and clea text me and said i was
up all night reading your book it was so
beautiful can we talk and then she
called me and you know basically said
like don't just sell your rights don't
just give this book away like this this
would make a beautiful tv show and we've
been friends 15 years and she was she
knows all the people that orbit in our
world and just had so many beautiful
ideas and um just was like you know come
and do this with me and sarah and i were
ecstatic we were like this is so fun
never imagined we'd actually do it but
it happened the three of you have known
each other for a while there's a lot of
trust in clia but going into this was
there anything that made you say
you can adapt our story into a tv show
as long as you make sure to do this
i don't think we were that specific but
i do think that there was
a like a learning curve because
you know we obviously
don't understand tv and film as as you
know as cellularly as clia does and i
think you know because we're still alive
and because these are like the closest
people in our lives like our family for
example i think there was a sensitivity
around needing to sort of be immersed in
in the process in a way that
um you know maybe other people wouldn't
need to be and mostly that's just to
sort of protect our own relationships to
our family and friends but probably also
our relationship as as collaborators you
know um tegan and i have had a long run
with each other as sisters like we're
going straight i haven't broken up with
her as my sister yeah it's we're about
to be 42 next week and i'm like
i feel like we're pretty good at
navigating um intense relationships but
you know you always want to sort of set
those boundaries because you just um you
know you don't want to you don't want to
you don't want to lose people over
something like this that's why likely
and laura were incredible collaborators
is because they were so patient with us
they let us
voice all those concerns and it was it
was amazing all right so clay i'm going
to throw that question to you because
like pressure collaboration but also a
friendship here so going into this
project was there any specific thing you
circled and you said like i need to do
this for my friends but also for the
project overall in bringing their story
to screen yeah i mean there were there
were certain things early on like
because we had so many conversations
early on to sort of establish what the
boundaries were because there were also
certain things in the book that they
didn't want in the show and like i
really you know i wanted to be sensitive
to them the people in their lives and
really you know if there's there was
anything that seemed questionable or
certain things that we wanted to change
because also like as laura and i got in
into like
breaking the season there were certain
things we're just like well what if this
happened to sarah instead of tegan and
things like that and so there was like a
constant checking in of like how does
this feel and is this okay and can we
take this liberty and like
you know it was really just like wanting
to do
you know wanting to do what was best
always wanted to do what was best for
the show as long as it wasn't at the
expense of tegan and sarah and the
people in their lives you know so it was
you know really navigating
that which was interesting because i had
never adopted anything before i'd always
like um i just have so many original
ideas you know
no i but it was you know so it was it
was like a daunting task and thank god i
had
laura with me
um on on the journey but like it you
know how it's a daunting task just
because it was such a beloved book and
but also that they you know my
relationship with tegan and sarah i just
wanted to get you know get out of it
with like a show that they felt really
good about um was my
number one priority and like well one
one and one a priority was like that
they were really happy but then also
like we all still liked each other
and could still be in the same room and
you know what you can't win them all
one out of two isn't bad to follow up on
something you said can you give us an
example of something from the book where
you were trying to figure out is this
going to benefit the show or should this
be removed and then why you decided
whatever ultimate way you went with that
i mean i feel like the things from the
book that we didn't put in the show i
think are things that maybe i don't
really feel like it's my place to talk
about because it is they were still
thinking there were things that tegan
and sarah wanted to protect so i still
like and it's not really i don't know
like i don't feel good about being like
well this and this and that you know you
can you can reveal our secrets clea it's
finally it's time it's really i just
we've always been very we've been really
closed off in private but we're ready to
finally tell just wait if we get a
season two we're gonna put everything
out there i thought it was actually when
you get a season two we manifest things
here getting a season two i thought it
was interesting the thing you were
saying about making that decision to
decide like there were story lines that
were tegan's storyline that you guys
thought should be like a sarah storyline
like i i've nev we've never really
talked about that like i'm
curious is it because i'm your favorite
that you gave me some of the stronger
moments from tegan's story um well it
was like as the show went on you know
the show kind of like we started with
the book but then the show kind of took
on a life of its own and then you know
the we we build this the season in a
certain way and then things start to
feel like you know they make sense they
make more sense for sarah as a character
in the television show you know because
it's you know tegan and sarah high
school is a memoir of their lives and
then high school is a tv show that's
based on that so it is like there is a
difference there and like the characters
the characters on tv are not tegan and
sarah even though they are tegan and
sarah you know they're like more
fictionalized
versions of them so it's
you know they you know
thanksgiving what she's trying to say is
that our tv please she had to make it
cooler too you know
equally cool in somewhat different ways
um laura i'll ask you to do the honors
of walking us through the casting
process because these two here are gems
and i know it can be like a little scary
and different to cast to actors as leads
in a show who have never done this type
of thing before so what gave you the
confidence that they were perfect for
the roles but also that they were ready
to jump into such a big production like
this
[Laughter]
i don't like this at all
[Laughter]
it's very cute um i mean we went through
a traditional audition process we saw a
lot of people we saw a lot of good
people um
but then
tegan on the tick tock algorithm
uh thank you tick-tock discovered these
two
sent the video to us we were like
they're very cute but absolutely not um
they've never acted before this seems
impossible um and then we actually had
them audition and they were incredible
and it was undeniable and then they
worked their butts off with an acting
coach and music teachers and just went
to real
musician and actor boot camp and
i mean
i think the first day of filming there
was this energy of like okay this entire
thing can like fall apart if they can't
do it and then i mean from the first
second it was like oh my god it's gonna
work it's gonna work and then i mean
throughout the whole season it's like
they just got better and better and i'm
very proud of them and
look at these little faces you should be
so proud of yourselves too you really
are something else in this when you get
these roles what is something about the
acting process that makes you think like
that's going to be really tough i'm
nervous about that and then ultimately
was that the most challenging thing or
did something about the process kind of
catch you by surprise
most intimidating part was
um just
like
just acting in general
god that was intimidating
and just learning how to like be able to
show what i
want to express on screen and be able to
do that and like feel those emotions and
be able to be um vulnerable in front of
you know a whole crew and the cast and
everybody
i would say that the most intimidating
part of the process was the process
and
and i think that um
also it was it was pretty intimidating
to know that they could have chosen
someone who
was an actor rather than
someone who was they just found online
and so that was pretty intimidating it
felt like it was
um a
[Music]
a responsibility to do to do well for
them
and
hopefully we did it guys
you really didn't make us all very proud
i know it's hard to find confidence in
yourself in any form of art and creation
but was there ever a moment either in
rehearsals or when you were on set where
something just clicked when you were
doing a scene and you said to yourselves
like you know what this feels right and
i feel like i am good at it um i feel
like that kind of came slowly like i i
was obviously you know doubting myself
here and there but i the acting lessons
and everything that helped so much and
was able to give me the confidence and
the support from everybody here gave me
so much confidence
um but yeah like slowly i just gained
more and more and i just felt more
comfortable
i asked this question a lot and i feel
like i get a long pause most of the time
just so you know
um i think i would agree with really it
was it was a slower process but
if there was if i had to think of a
specific time i think
for me showing emotion was really hard
to do on screen and so there was there
was a specific time where i had to do
that and i
i felt as as if i was
happy with with what i had done and i
was okay with it and
and so that would be one of the times
that i could say i'm not leaving you too
yet because i love asking this question
to newer actors because i know sometimes
when you're new to a world like this it
can be scary to ask questions and kind
of reveal you don't know something so
after going through the process of
making a whole season of a show is there
any seemingly silly question about the
way shows are made that you wish you had
asked earlier on that you think a new
actor out there would benefit from
learning about i mean during shooting
there was like a million questions that
i was asking
so
i don't i wouldn't know exactly what
what to say for that because i asked
every single one in the book
do you have a favorite one of the bunch
or one that you think someone else would
find most helpful to learn about
um to you
because i don't
no
you're just pros you'll teach everybody
else out there based on what you do in
the finished product maybe what's really
cool about what they did was they asked
questions i think that was the maturity
is they weren't afraid to ask questions
yeah kyle come your way next
what was it like working with the two of
them as scene partners because i imagine
you don't really get the opportunity so
often to work with brand new actors who
are jumping into their first project so
what was it about them that caught you
by surprise and you appreciate it i mean
i was in it from the beginning i was in
love with this entire group the minute
we got on a zoom call together and i
never
felt like a mo i and clia can speak that
we all feel like we're new that every
time we step on a set so like i i
wouldn't even know how to answer that in
terms of it's the same it's like yeah
sometimes i feel pretty good and other
times i go home at night wishing i had
done something different and it's like
that's pretty consistent throughout your
career and um
this group their entire you know their
their entire
uh
just personalities off screen and when
they were working was i was in it from
the beginning i never had a moment of i
mean i was well taken care of by their
writing and by cleo's directing and um
it was a joy the whole time and it's fun
that's sort of the joy of film and
television acting is you are going you
almost know you're going to be in with
everyone that's been doing it for 30
years and comes from the royal
shakespeare company to someone that
that just got an opportunity because
they're hilarious on tick tock to a
buddy that you've been doing bits for
with your whole life there's another
friend of mine nate cordrey that's in
the show
um so you always know you're going to be
in with this amazing mix and that's
really the fun and for clia to sort of
wrangle that and have incredible
confidence in her directing skills too
to have all those people and know which
buttons to push when to sit back when to
not do i mean she has an amazing light
touch with it and um
so it was it was a joy and easy and but
also fun and and um
engaging and curious we were all asking
like questions about these kinds of
things you know what the character might
do the interpretation like you said the
journey from the the very fact based
memoir to interpreting that into a show
to then actors coming in having their
own take and saying oh they play with
each other differently that might affect
like a decision we make down the line
and that's okay the tremendous
confidence that he can say and shown in
cli and laura in
in the adaptation process to be like
yeah this the show will will take on
life of its own and we're we trust you
with that it's it was fun to be part of
that i have to let you guys go soon but
i don't want to end this interview
without bringing kobe up at least once
because i've seen a lot of good work
from her but my god so cle i want to
throw this to you because i know you two
have collaborated and you've known each
other for a very very long time but even
with all that experience is there
anything she did on the sh on the show
that made even you go like damn i didn't
realize you were capable of that
i mean i think
it's a it was such a tricky character
because their mom is such a like
specific
amazing woman who is like
strong but compassionate and like funny
and interesting and so layered and
it was you know and it was like tricky
to crack her on the page you know and
then i i think that we really did
um
um and thank you for saying that
i was gonna go the other way with the
joke and then i was like no i'm gonna
redirect you
um no but then you know so and kobe is
just she is such a wonderful actor and i
was like but you still just don't know
what's gonna happen and like i had
worked with her before and she surprised
me in so many ways but the character
that she played in in my movie was so
different from
from
simone um
we changed the names um
very late in the game so i think we all
still say the other names um
but you know so
when it was i think the amount of humor
that she was able to find in it because
obviously like there there's humor
written in but there was like a levity
to her like being able to play the
duality of that levity but also that
toughness
she just nailed that it's like such a
fine line and she just i was i was so
blown away by her all the time like i
was so excited to see when she was
coming into a scene like how she was
gonna do it and it was really and she's
also just like the most wonderful actor
to work with she is so generous to
everybody on set she is just this like
bright light she's so silly and fun and
i just i just i love her so much she's
the best i lie i'm going to throw in one
more question it's going to make me
sound greedy because you're giving a
show now happy season two when
when i don't know i don't know maybe
never i just signed my paperwork so um i
mean it's a new story the world wants it
i i would love i would love to do it i
would love to do it i think you know
it's a it's a very busy group of people
and
um i mean we'll see maybe someday i
again i like manifesting things so i had
to say that so you know what keep saying
it listen i'll do it i'll do it i have
to let you go congratulations on your
show i absolutely adore it to everybody
out there keep an eye out for high
school trust me when i tell you it is a
gem you do not want to miss it and stay
tuned we'll have more interviews from
the supper suite for you soon
you